okay there you go have a good night  enjoy  how can i get you a little young for a  bartender aren't you take that as a  compliment a little old for prom aren't  you  well  fundraiser around the corner 10k seating  in on how to make a damn hemingway deck  papa doble it is  you can have it by the book  splash of grapefruit splash of  maraschino or you can have it the way  the old man in the sea used to drink it  straight rum extra coal and just a few  drops of lime and a teaspoon of sugar  just like they do at the florida bar  floor d like hemingway florida you've  been a bunch of times i don't always  remember walking out sounds like my kind  of night i always wanted to go to havana  yeah well what's stopping you  well you're this way  i'm not dropping 10k at fundraisers  i'll sell yourself short kid you'd be  surprised how far you can go